she was pretty different you know it was
a is a custom-built shoot around Kai
Lenny who is gonna be wearing a suit so
it's nothing like what we've done in the
past where it's it's just action action
action you really had to think more
about fashion and action so you told me
this morning he felt so empowered by
wearing the suit and he feels a smart in
it that uh
the double pleasure for him you know
being so good at what he does and he
dressed in a suit how unusual
what you get with KY to us is is pretty
much we've been working with ty for a
really long time each person that was on
this crew holding a camera has been
filming thi over the years we had pretty
much an all-star crew and and each one
of them have specific skill sets that
are incredible and very detailed this
whole crew is basically like one big
family if you're gonna wear a suit got
to wear it wet if you're an oi
do you want to see me do more cool stuff
check out me windsurfing kitesurfing
stand up paddle wording in a suit on the
GPU channel